this great big story was made possible
by PNG love / bias batter up is a
competition
it's gladiator style without the weapons
it's a verbal warfare it gets ugly but
it's the most entertaining thing you
will ever see in your life my name is
Sarah Connor I've been in battle rap for
over 30 years
New York City born Bronx rave
battle rap is one person versus the
other person with words and it's just a
battle of wits of back and forth answer
one of the reasons I decide to battle
rap is because when you come from the
Bronx and your kid and you're running
the streets of your hip hop's child and
that's just what I am
prison battle league is the only
platform right now currently
concentrating on opening the doors for
LGBTQ at bat Iraq
I started prison batter league in
January 2016 because there needed to be
a platform for lesbian queer bisexual
transexual gave whoever you are being
LGBTQ and anything hip-hop is usually
frowned upon and prism is changing that
I don't want to hear you know oh you're
you're dope for a gay guy you got lyrics
for a gig I just wanted you to hear the
bars never take away my sexuality
because I'm proud of Who I am at the end
of the day but I want you to hear what
I'm saying
homophobia is a real and hip-up
president gives people a voice it gives
people an option to speak out gives
people a home
one of the reason why I decided to
self-fund prism and why I'm so
passionate is because I grew up being a
different person and I'll never let
nobody do that for anybody people to
this day look down on me and no matter
how many times they look down on me I
rise above it
sarah has definitely guided me in the
right path
she showed me you know that you can do
this and I am forever grateful to her
when I was somebody from prison battle
it's an overwhelming feeling almost like
a mom feeling like you know these are my
babies seeing these people get on
platforms they would never be on get the
recognition they deserve I'll go broke
before I let them down
[Music]
you